[Musica]
noi siamo beh sì in realtà siamo da
sempre schemi da quando nasciamo abbiamo
praticamente una serie di informazioni
di caratteristiche che ci vengono
assegnate da tutto ciò che ci circonda
dai familiari in primis ma sicuramente
anche dalla fata dalla società comunque
in generale
questi schemi sono la nostra
rappresentazione che a prescindere da
quello che poi siamo realmente e quindi
legati a quello che potrebbe essere
comunque una situazione tipicamente
costituzionale rappresenteranno il
nostro vivere nella comunità nella
società e nella sessualità
beh nella sessualità è un aspetto molto
particolare perché perché nella
sessualità diventano stereotipi
stereotipi pesantissimi perché ho
sentito parlare anche prima altri
colleghi nello speech rispetto agli
stereotipi di genere voglio partire
proprio da questo quando nascono dei
bambini in realtà dovremmo essere felici
semplicemente perché nasce una nuova
vita e quindi in qualche modo dovremmo
essere pronti a rappresentare al sociale
la nuova vita in realtà non funziona
così nasce subito uno schema uno schema
molto forte e molto pazzesco direi
perché perché i genitori fanno a gara ad
appendere fiocchi
coccarde e guardate un po rosa e azzurri
si sa mai che siano un altro colore
perché perché perché dobbiamo dimostrare
comunque di essere stato in grado di
aver fatto un maschio o una femmina non
un bambino e questo è uno stereotipo
immaginate quanto questi bambini sin da
piccolissimi si porteranno sulle proprie
spalle questa caratteristica senza
volerlo senza saperlo anche perché in
realtà e immaginate che l'identità di
genere quindi la rappresentazione di noi
stessi se si come maschi e come femmine
avverra molto più tardi intorno ai 3
anni più o meno i bambini si
riconosceranno proprio anche avendo
definito se stessi nominandosi poco
prima e poi con la pubertà quindi molto
molto più avanti e nello stesso tempo
però l'aspetto alla nascita
inconsapevolmente viene rimarcato
proprio dagli stessi genitori quando io
spiego l'identità di genere o comunque
l'identità sessuale perché forse sarebbe
molto più utile parlare di identità
sessuale rappresentata appunto dalle
caratteristiche biologiche l'identità di
genere l'espressione di genere e
l'orientamento sessuale in realtà mi
aspetto sempre di rompere un po questo
schema questo stereotipo perché
decifrando la spiegandola dando anche
dei riferimenti scientifici che non darò
oggi naturalmente cerco di far capire
alle persone che forse quando nasce un
bambino potrebbe essere importante
rappresentare semplicemente la nascita
di quella vita di quella nuova vita
allora quando alcuni dei miei studenti o
comunque delle persone che mi conoscono
mi mandano delle foto di fiocchi gialli
verdi arcobaleno eccoli mi sento un po
più rassicurato perché dico finalmente
finalmente qualcosa sta cambiando
qualcosa cambia all'interno di quello
che è la rappresentazione di uno schema
che sembra così di base ma che non vuole
essere
negativo vuole essere trasformativo
perché quando poi le persone sono adulte
e non riescono ad essere libere di
essere se stesse ricordiamocelo questo
schema perché probabilmente parte
veramente da molto molto molto indietro
la sessualità è la sessualità
quindi diventa sicuramente procreativa
sarebbe sciocco dimenticarcelo però mi
piacerebbe sottolineare quanto la
sessualità è anche divertimento
perché e divertimento perché il fatto di
riuscire a divertirsi nell'erotismo
significa rappresentare
in buona parte delle espressioni di sé
in libertà in serenità in tranquillità e
vi posso garantire che nella maggior
parte dei casi questa cosa non avviene
non avviene perché perché comunque il
fatto di giocare soprattutto nelle
coppie anche di lunga durata a un certo
punto scema e se ne va via se ne va via
cioè perde di significato non ha quel
giusto è quella giusta intensità per
permettere di stare bene insieme
rinnovando costantemente la fase
dell'innamoramento
ricordate però l'innamoramento dura poco
poi dopo c'è l'amore però nell'amore se
non si rinnova costantemente
l'innamoramento
secondo me oggi come oggi i rischi delle
coppie sono altissimi o almeno questo è
quello che poi io vedo da un punto di
vista clinico
eppure noi abbiamo un ormone lo sito
cina si chiama addirittura l'ormone
della felicità e lo si tu cena viene
rilasciata in tantissime esperienze
della vita umana ma moltissimo
all'interno di quella che è la
rappresentazione appunto dell'erotismo e
della sessualità e quando viene
rilasciato il sito cina beh sicuramente
quando stiamo molto bene quando siamo
molto eccitati e quando arriviamo a
quello che è effettivamente la fase poi
culmine l'orgasmo
se io vi chiedessi che cos'è l'orgasmo
riuscireste a rappresentarlo in realtà
la vedo molto dura perché al di là di
harry ti presento sally e quindi il
fatto di riuscire no a simulare
l'orgasmo al tavolo di un ristorante
tendenzialmente l'orgasmo è
rappresentativo di volti di espressioni
di suoni di una serie di elementi
importanti che rappresentano in quel
momento il lasciarsi andare
il non controllarsi
immaginate che una caratteristica
particolare nel genere umano è che
l'uomo tende a controllare continuamente
o ci prova e la donna invece a
raggiungere in qualche modo di lasciarsi
andare perché perché sembra difficile e
tutto questo in una delle esperienze più
importanti del nostro essere umani
quella del essere appunto orgasmici
orgasmici che mi viene da dire
nella donna
forse ancora di più una donna che nel o
perché l'uomo avendo un contatto diretto
anche con l'orgasmo associato
all'eiaculazione è tutto molto più
semplice la donna invece deve in qualche
modo concentrarsi e a volte si continua
a fare delle domande tipo orgasmo
clitorideo orgasmo vaginale e io dico no
aspettate non fate confusione non
entrate in questo ginepraio che
effettivamente molto complesso
l'orgasmo è 1 cioè fisiologicamente
l'orgasmo 1 e anche se non voglio farvi
una lezione accademica però vi vorrei
spiegare che l'orgasmo è dettato da
contrazioni involontarie nella zona già
ito pelvica
nello specifico per quanto riguarda la
donna ancora un po più adesso è la
contrazione involontaria del terzo
esterno del canale vaginale sì avete
capito bene terzo esterno del canale
significa la partner la parte più
prossima all'uscita e all'entrata in
quel caso che genera un certo punto
nella parte anteriore una platform che
si chiama platform orgasmica che creando
delle contrazioni involontarie
improvvisamente generano l'orgasmo cioè
quello che effettivamente è la
rappresentazione del massimo il punto di
piacere
sessualità quindi è complessa sessualità
complessita mi verrebbe da dire no
sessualità nello specifico ci
rappresenta anche all'interno di che
cosa di quello che è normativo cose che
sembra giusto fare è importante fare
patologiche assolutamente negative
sbagliate questo non si fa perché
comunque se fai questo se addirittura
perverso mi verrebbe da dire oppure
semplicemente criminali semplicemente
per modo di dire perché quelle forse
sono realmente le situazioni negative lo
stupro la violenza è comunque la
sessualità c'è sempre dentro quando ho
iniziato a studiare se la sessualità e
la sessuologia mi sono reso conto che
questi tre schemi questi tre contenitori
forse non bastavano perché perché
intanto erano troppo rigidi era troppo
comodo in qualche modo rimandare
rimarcare il fatto che una persona
poteva sentirsi normale visto che io
dico che la normalità non esiste oppure
patologica e si ok non sto bene quindi
c'è qualche disturbo c'è qualcosa che
non va oppure criminale e allora
sicuramente viene anche arrestata a
riguardo ho deciso di creare un qualcosa
che fosse un po più fluido un po più
come dire continuativo all'interno della
sessualità e quindi ho deciso di
rappresentarlo con questo continuum che
ok ai due estremi
noi abbiamo la normatività e il sex
offender ex fi ni significa appunto la
parte criminale no della violenza sera
ci sono tutta una serie di altre cose
importanti secondo me all'interno che
non starò qui adesso a spiegarvelo nel
dettaglio ma mi vorrei concentrare
soprattutto su quella della
trasgressione perché il trans mine il
termine trasgredire che solitamente
viene fatto a come dire associato a un
accezione negativa e non positiva perché
uno dice se trasgredisco faccio qualcosa
che non dovrei fare in realtà io la
vorrei vedere come la possibilità che le
persone si danno di sentirsi libere di
fare un qualcosa che realmente sentono e
che vorrebbero fare soprattutto se
associamo a questo il rispetto nei
confronti dell'altro oltre che nel
gruppo nei confronti di se stessi
ecco allora che nel trasgredire noi
abbiamo le trasgressioni ma
trasgressione l'erotismo nella
sessualità in una libertà in un consenso
sono aspetti veramente molto particolari
tutti noi probabilmente facciamo
fantasie forse pochi di noi le mettono
in pratica
ma tutti noi stiamo dentro la
trasgressione a questo punto e qual è la
massima caratteristica che a volte le
persone di cui a volte le persone hanno
anche paura è sicuramente quella
rappresentata dal bdsm non so quanti di
voi conoscono ma il bdsm è un acronimo
che è rappresentato praticamente
da una serie di comportamenti di
caratteristiche che spesso vengono viste
come sbagliate e io dico no forse sono
realmente trasgressive non sbagliate
perché dentro il bdsm ci sono delle
regole importanti
l'abi sta per bondage quindi le gare
farsi legare e io dico e aggiungo una
cosa importante legame due persone che
si legano o una che lega l'altra genera
comunque un'unione un legame e legame è
affetto non è solo eros possesso è vero
si cela di di dominanza no o comunque di
disciplina d'accordo poi vi farò vedere
anche un'immagine che sicuramente
rappresenta questa dominanza ok un po
forte però anche se forte secondo me è
importante riconoscerlo come aspetto
solo trasgressivo e poi esseri sadismo m
di masochismo e vabbè qui allora hai
detto qualcosa che non va bene quattrini
perché come dire sadomasochismo è
sicuramente patologico è no perché se ci
sono delle regole vuol dire che le
persone che vivono una realtà
sadomasochista molto probabilmente sono
contente serene e entusiaste del loro
vivere questo erotismo quali sono le
regole le regole del bdsm sono poche ma
essenziali
ssc sano sicuro e consensuale cosa
significa in realtà significa che le
persone all'interno
questa dimensione anno il che è la piena
libertà di
definire e negoziare anche quelli che
possono essere limiti addirittura
aggiungendo una cosa importante che si
chiama sanford ovvero una parola di
salvataggio che permette una volta
decisa all'inizio del gioco di
interrompere il gioco quando il gioco si
fa troppo pesante beh ma la forza non
avreste mai pensato una cosa del genere
immaginate quanto questo all'interno di
un erotismo diventa estremamente
schematizzato estremamente importante
eppure tanti continuano a dire che fa
bdsm è malato è strano in realtà tutto
ciò che ruota intorno alle pratiche che
vengono chiamate kinky bizzarre atipiche
ma trasgressive si oppongono a quello
che ha il sesso vaniglia e quindi una
sessualità più morbida più conformante
più naturale o comunque forse più
monotona non lo so però le pratiche
kinky sono delle pratiche importanti
perché ad esempio partendo da delle cose
molto più soft
potremmo definire kinky anche i sex toys
sicuramente tanti di voi utilizzano sex
toys e non si sentono trasgressivi e
dico guardate già li state facendo
trasgressione perché il sex toys
probabilmente è un'esperienza
alternativa a quella di una realtà
normativa e il sex toys però va
conosciuto va capito come può essere
utilizzato bisogna come dire imparare a
non farsi male con i sex toys ci sono
persone che si fanno male anche come sex
toys oppure la forno grafia oppure i
giochi di ruolo molto interessanti no e
interessanti perché sembrano
accattivanti sembrano strani ma poi
generano quella situazione di prima o
sito cina uguale orgasmo ma anche il
folle amore e trasgressione
oggi si parla tanto di poli amore o
comunque come forse sarebbe più giusto
parlare di non monogamia consensuali
parola molto particolare in realtà i
poli amorosi sono sempre esistiti da che
mondo è mondo però oggi sembra quasi
essere diventata una moda dico io e non
è vero non è né una moda è né un
qualcosa di sbagliato e forse una
trasgressione perché significa vivere
all'interno di una realtà molto più
allargata e quindi non una famiglia
monogamica come conosciamo ma una realtà
molto più aperta dove all'interno ci
sono sia gli aspetti dell'affettività e
sicuramente anche quelli della
sessualità e questi gli scambisti e
scambisti peggio era questi sono
trasgressivi forti però vi siete mai
chiesti chi sono realmente persone che
fanno scambismo visto che poi tante
persone magari lo negano e poi sono i
primi ad avere una tessera di un club
privè in realtà e lo scambista è forse
la massima espressione della sicurezza
di una coppia
pensate un po sapete perché perché la
coppia scambista decide di scambiare il
partner di fare un gioco con la
sessualità insieme ad altri partner ma
poi se si va a vedere la parte quella
strettamente relazionale sono loro due
sono loro due non sono tanti altri
quelli eventualmente sarebbero i famosi
di polia morosi prima quindi lo scan
vista è sì trasgressivo ma nello stesso
tempo è una persona che si concede la
possibilità di vivere la libertà del
gioco del gioco nella sessualità
feticismi piedi scarpe
tessuti tutti elementi che io sono
convinto tantissime persone utilizzano
nell'immaginario almeno e poi però
negano a loro stessi o almeno non
riescono a riferirlo agli altri perché
perché si sentirebbero sbagliati e io
dico no trasgressione trasgressivi non
siete sbagliati non è questo
parte forte spanking
sculacciare beh lo speck in realtà ormai
viene preso quasi di mira semplicemente
perché l'ho visto fare a rocco siffredi
in un video hard beh no diamogli un
significato un po più importante cioè
quella percorsa sulla le natiche forse
genera una sensazione particolare che
può piacere alla persona percossa c'è
anche un'altra pratica che non ve la
faccio vedere che è molto più pesante il
bar busting che è comunque percuotere le
zone intime maschili eppure anche quello
non è un qualcosa di sbagliato lo sapete
perché perché quando a me è capitato una
volta di fare di andare in una serata di
queste dove c'era tutta questa
trasgressione
mi colpì molto il fatto di può osservare
una persona che si stava facendo
prendere a calci nelle zone intime e lì
però io mi resi conto di una cosa
importante perché anche io gli feci o
mio dio cosa sta succedendo e se lo dico
io guardatela veramente pesante e dissi
a un certo punto dissi no sta succedendo
la cosa che non immaginavo la persona
aveva un erezione
l'elezione è uguale all'eccitazione vuol
dire che quei calci dati in un posto
molto delicato procurava una citazione
fantastico vuol dire quella persona nel
suo vivere la libertà riusciva a vivere
un piacere e un orgasmo in una pratica
che personalmente non farei mai però va
bene rispettabilissimo tickling fare il
solletico traverso l'etico lo facciamo
tutti no poi lo facciamo sicuramente
anche da bambini
ma pensate di farlo da allegati o le
gare una persona e fargli il solletico
diventa una tortura una tortura che però
potrebbe essere effettivamente
generatrice di piacere a tante persone
può piacere oppure il discorso del tram
ping fare trampling significa mettere in
atto un comportamento di pressioni con
scarpe tacchi con piedi che permette
effettivamente a chi le riceve di vivere
un'intensa sensazione di piacere
mummificazione guardate sto crescendo
nelle trasgressioni unificazione
privazione totale delle sensorialità a
volte si può fare semplicemente facendo
bendare gli occhi è molto più semplice
in questi casi diventa estrema io dico
sempre chi la vuole fare naturalmente
ben venga deve essere preparato e non
deve soffrire ad attacchi d'ansia perché
tutti imbacuccati così diventa veramente
complicato
chiudo con questa immagine che non è
come dire l'ultima per minore importanza
un mini maggiore importanza in realtà
questi si chiamano adult baby
infantilismo tanti direbbero persone che
trasgrediscono nell'erotismo
regredendo però lì mi viene in mente
stiamo attenti non giudichiamo perché la
dott.sa di vuole solamente anche lì
ritornare ad uno spazio protetto per
diversi un piacere ben venga e
trasgressione lo so è tutto strano vi
sto parlando di situazioni che sono
effettivamente complesse che sono o mio
dio no non posso accettarlo io dico
impariamo a non giudicare perché forse
la cosa più importante
l'ho sentito dire tantissimo oggi dagli
altri colleghi
è giusto la libertà è imparare a non
giudicare l'altro anche perché dobbiamo
vivere una sessualità positiva è la
stessa sessualità positiva significa
rispetto con sensualità uguaglianza
rispetto al genere e agli orientamenti e
anche un accettazione di quello che
potrebbe essere una situazione legata
alla nonna sessualità gli asessuali
chiudo dicendo il sesso non è una
cattiva cosa ricordiamo solo perché
praticamente la cattiva cosa è quella di
negare alle persone il diritto delle
informazioni rispetto alla sessualità
grazie
[Applauso]